if your spouse cannot stand your friends
it could have a negative effect on your
marriage
researchers pored over 16 years of data
for 2017 study they looked at responses
from 355 newlywed couples who
participated in a University of Michigan
survey couples were asked questions like
does your wife or husband have friends
that you would rather she or he not
spend time with Wall Street Journal
reporter Elizabeth Bernstein wrote about
how these friendships can strain
marriages in her latest column and she
joins us at the table welcome back
thanks Rob
so we've been fascinated by this
discussion we've been having in since
our editorial meeting yesterday because
it's such an intriguing study and I just
was sort of wondering if it's the reason
that it may affect men and women
differently is that women tend to have
much longer or more integral
relationships with their girlfriends and
dudes we're just sort of like if you
don't like the woman that your friend is
dating you're like yeah not gonna really
say anything not gonna stay on my place
it's exactly it does exactly relate to
male-female friendships so the women
have these intimate deep friendships
with their friends their female friends
especially we're gonna share everything
and talk men are gonna golf they're
gonna sail they're gonna go to things
together and don't know I do cause
problems if the guy doesn't like the
woman's friends so he doesn't like her
friends several things he could be
intimidated by the intimacy she's
sharing with a friend he could be
jealous of it he could be worried she's
talking about him you know all of these
things can be sort of threatening to him
he may feel there's not intimacy in my
or the relationship the marriage so why
are you spending more time or talking to
her about things you should talk to me
so the odds of divorce are higher if the
male doesn't like his wife's exactly the
office especially when he thinks that
she those friends are interfering yeah
it was interesting to see that that race
also plays a role in this research tell
us about that it's interesting because
this effect where he doesn't like her
friends they're more likely to divorce
that affects was stronger for white
couples so the black couples were a
little protected and the researchers
believe it's probably because black
couples blacks have maybe more strong
family ties or they look to their family
more for this kind of nurturing and
support and maybe that was it they also
maybe
have stronger church communities there's
other protective things around those
couples if my best friend didn't like my
husband or the guy I was dating that
would give me pause because I would
think what does she see that I don't as
opposed to you're wrong about him
exactly so and that's another reason why
he's probably worried Wow
what is she saying what is that friend
saying about me is my wife or partner
listening to that person why doesn't it
work the reverse for guys cuz they don't
care because they're just not talking it
really just not they aren't sharing as
much he is not blabbing about his wife
most likely even one men are getting
divorce I've seen their know exactly
Elizabeth I've seen guys go through
divorce and they haven't even told their
friends they're going to her exactly so
they're just not sharing as much it's
not as threatening to that relationship
also a woman tends to control sort of
the social life of the couple so she
doesn't like his friends you know
they're gonna go so clearly their
underlying problems than just not liking
it rattling what are some tips that
couples can work on a situation or you
want to really first understand that
there are other people in your marriage
so we often think in-laws can be very
meddling but you have to understand
there are friends in this marriage
they're part of it really so that's
number one
you want to understand then what is that
issue I don't like your friends but why
don't I like them she's a drama queen or
she's a bad influence or I'm feeling
threatened you want to get at that
underlying issue because even if you got
rid of the friend it's gonna come back
later I think that though you may be
able to have a situation where the guy
is attending to win over the girlfriends
because you know that they play such an
important role in the life of your
spouse or your significant other and so
you'd want them taking from personal
experience person I try to you know
defensive the guys trying to win over
the friends it's smart that's you know
cuz it's good you what you want you
these hopefully you will have friends
they're awesome right for people there
they support your spouse they support
your marriage so it's good to bring them
in all right thank you Elizabeth this is
very interesting very interesting stuff
good to see you